بعد حرب المواقع في اوكرانيا وغياب اي
مكاسب لافته لكيف وحرب المواقع في المجلس
الاوروبي والخلافات العميقه منذ شهرين بين
فيكتور اوربان رئيس الوزراء المجري وبين
القاده الاوروبيين حول حزمه المساعدات
الماليه الاوروبيه لاوكرانيا توصلت الدول
ال 27 الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
اتفاق حول تقديم مساعده بقيمه 50 مليار
يورو لمده اربع سنوات لاوكرانيا كانت
مجمده سابقا بسبب رفض اوربان رئيس المجلس
اوروبي شارل ميشيل كتب على منصه اكس
قائلا اتفق كل القاده ال7 على مساعده
اضافيه بقيمه 50 مليار يورو لدعم اوكرانيا
كجزء من ميزانيه الاتحاد الاوروبي يضمن
تمويلا مستقرا على المدى الطويل
لاوكرانيا وكان رئيس الوزراء المجاري
الوحيد بين قاده دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
الذي حافظ على علاقات وثيقه مع الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بعد الغزو الروسي
لاوكرانيا قبل سنتين تقريبا وقد اثار غضب
نظرائه في ديسمبر من العام الماضي حين
طالب بمراجعه سنويه للدعم المالي لكيف
وحصول المجر على حق الفيتو اوربان معروف
بمواقفه المتشدده حيال المهاجرين وما يصفه
بالدعايه النسويه وحقوق المثليين رئيس
الوزراء المجاري يواجه ايضا اتهامات في
بروكسل بانه يقوم بابتزاز الاتحاد
الاوروبي للحصول على الافراج عن اموال
اوروبيه مخصصه
لبلاده m